do you like my new bomb I love your bomb  how are you girl gets the haircut it  gives her a new vibe because I'm not  feeling what's your in fact I feel  high-end and luxurious I feel and also I  like I felt like my sexy was connected  to my hair and I cut it off and I was  like I was like damn I look good who  designed your dream con custom custom  you know you're a baller when you got  custom name I know Ashley walked the vm  a white carpet with her husband Justin  Irvine who made it pretty obvious he's  one proud hubby  I'm just Olivia accessory I got to make  it look good she came out were you like  what was your reaction  Joe hit the floor I had to have like her  assistant and her stylist help pick it  up how proud are you if I love Ashley  thick that says she's just going from  strength to strength I would say I  couldn't be prouder but I'm excited to  see what else she's gonna do that's  gonna make me even prouder than am now  it's incredible